oh i don't know do you guys feel how do
you feel optimistic pessimistic and let
me just preface this with uh we had dr
robert murphy on economist smart guy and
man that conversation was brutal he was
like oh wait robert murphy murphy nice
awesome my other cousin yeah
check it out he said
the reserve requirements for banks to
give out loans has been removed because
of covid and then i was just like
there's no reserve requirement no
they did it like on a friday night at 10
p.m
wait wait wait wait so there's not even
a fractional reserves no anymore it's a
no reserve system now this is
presentable
it's literally just fraud it's literally
just fraud that's what that's called
fraud you're just loaning out a bunch of
money you don't have that that explains
why the reverse repo rate is like 1.2
trillion dollars daily now what does
that mean uh it's where like the banks
and the fed like swap securities and
swap money in order to back up the fact
that they've loaned out all their money
and don't have anything on the books
which is actually good for the economy
in the long term i hear yeah is that
right it's really good yeah that's
really good yeah the economy being gold
bitcoin land yes yes no that's true i
mean i'm not going to give financial i
was about to give myself financial
advice but there's a little sheet here
that tells me not to give financials
but you almost work for goldman sachs so
i'm saying that's true no no no no no
you can give financial advice it's just
you're legally like you're bound no
that's not that's real
uh financial advice i mean you can give
financial advice to legal advisor
medical advice but then you're liable
for like you know someone will be like
sheamus told me to take the phone would
it be the stream that it was set on
would also become liable so like there's
chains of liability if you start doing
it no no basically you're going to go
back to your what we try to tell people
is like when we're talking about bitcoin
and stuff make sure you're like i'm not
advising you on anything yeah that's on
you
yeah well i didn't say anything then
before the show we were talking about
doing a bit i was like what if we just
like make up a bunch of random
ingredients to say in the vaccine just
off the top of our heads that would be
great for tim's channel it's like
flintstones yeah
i'm way more optimistic today than i was
yesterday i realized last night that i
thought i'd been building out the
fetavers because we've been working on
this decentralized social media app
basically that's going to come
what we're really building is the
metaverse which is ultimately artificial
intelligence augmented reality finance
and social media conglomerating and do
it like an internet 3.0 but we're
starting with we're building the first
leg of it which is the federal social
social media aspect decentralized
self-sustaining social media tools for
people who want to run their own you
know have their own internet presence in
any capacity it's gonna be epic and
other people are building the other legs
as we're doing it and i'm finding today
that that people are contacting me and
then we're we're merging you know
software this is why crypto is so
important right now just i want everyone
to remember exactly jack's reaction when
he was like there's no reserve
requirement for banks i had not heard
that the price of bitcoin went up but
when he said that
here's the crazy thing too like we
talked about this with with bob murphy
the m1 money supply
you can watch it just go forward and it
just like skyrockets and everyone always
goes tim you're wrong they just changed
the definition of how they define money
supply and then you look after they
change the definition and it's
skyrocketing in like a 90 or like an 80
degree angle and i'm like yo this is why
all the ultra wealthy people are buying
properties sight unseen in places like
west virginia and idaho
you know let me just say real quick just
one point
if you've been tracking the real estate
market i don't know if you've seen this
jack i'm calling agents because we're
like we want to expand we need more
space and the stories i'm hearing
agent says i got a call the other day
they said i'll take it and i was like do
you want to have a meeting do you need
finance i'm like no i said i'll take it
they're like do you want to see it no i
said i'll take it where do i wire the
money like that because people who live
in these big cities who have cash no the
cash is worthless and they're like i
need to get this in something it's a
guarantee land
lands a guarantee
for the most
so i think we would all agree that if
inflation's occurring and it's going to
get worse but the question is will the
real estate bubble outpace inflation
ah people got to live somewhere yeah so
i think yes what'll i think it will i i
think there could be a crash
but
if i i'm not i'm not a financial expert
look if you if you just value the land
in terms of dollars you get you have
fixed amount of land yeah and you get
more dollars well it's just going to go
up in dollar value yeah yeah but if it's
a bubble though and that bubble pops and
then the property is worth significantly
less right so so like the bubble in 2008
was was because uh there was lacks
underwriting standards you could get
loans if you had no income you had no
assets you could lie about everything
ninja loans etc so that was a bubble
created through a lack of underwriting
and regulatory oversight and stuff this
is just straight price inflation because
there's just more money chasing a fixed
amount of product and so you are giving
me financial advice i am just really
talking about economics that's it
i'm i'm i'm thinking it's the same thing
you know i'm looking at crypto i'm
looking at crypto prices i'm looking at
the manipulation of the crypto market
i'm just thinking my attitude is man do
i do not want to have us dollars yeah
i went on a rock and stone frenzy and
bought a bunch of opals and i was like
wow have you looked at an opal it's
silica silicon dioxide in water because
they always save this help if you're
going to invest are you talking about
you're going to invest your money
invested in gold silver jewels like gems
gems are legit because i don't know
something about looking into a gem like
a really unique gem man that is
transforming please don't let that be
your finances the land but it was like
land or gems well let's do both well i'm
giving you a hard time because you
caught me very off guard there i've
never heard someone say that they're
like investing in gems i was like oh i'm
investing in jail i didn't realize until
after i was doing it i will say maybe to
that yeah assuming the system exists and
inflation happens then the value of
these items will go up along with the
value of most items buy for 80 bucks
there's nothing like it on earth and you
know what i don't think people are
rushing for that the way they are for
gold or silver exactly orlando so i
laughed it ian but
i got a lot
i want everyone to just remember it's
going to be in like five years you're
going to be on the side of the road
going like these opals and ian's going
to walk up with a shot
a shiny suit encrusted and opal
spinning his opal cane and he's going to
be like i got your opponent's right your
50 bucks contain up to 30 water
and and you'll drink that let's pay for
that yeah you can see it like refracts
through the silicon dioxide okay
meanwhile meanwhile wealthy elites are
buying up land like crazy yeah because
if you know we had mexico on the show he
said he said inflation was what fourteen
percent
what they're telling us is five percent
yeah fourteen percent so it's just like
you gotta invest it in something you
gotta put it somewhere but if that's the
case buy a brand new car
yeah
i'm sorry sheamus man
it's almost i gotta say like ian's opel
thing kind of makes sense but
are things brand new all right they're
only gonna go up in value
i don't i don't know like what would you
guys think a regular a regular person
should do i mean how much how much does
the average person have in savings a few
hundred bucks well that's a good
question our economy has actually been
designed over the past 50 years to
disincentivize savings so most people
don't and they'll come out here with
these
you know
the left will tote these studies and the
right doesn't discuss it as often but
the left will tote these studies saying
oh the average person doesn't have
enough saved up to get them through an
emergency if one occurs
and that's true but what they don't
point out is that is not the result of
inadequate social welfare spending the
reason for that is because we are
constantly inflating our currency and
people know that their money isn't going
to be worth as much in the future as it
is today so you actually alter their
time preference and make them more
likely to spend in the moment the idea
behind this is that stimulates the
economy but of course what you're doing
is taking from the future because people
aren't saving as much yeah they're not
and they're also not learning to defer
their appetites which is a really
important part of having a civil society
and i thought you were just the cartoon
guy yeah i know he said murphy thought i
was an idiot he's like
he still does but he thought i said that
nice come on bobby murphy so you're
preaching temperance
yeah it's a big part of it it is a
virtue yeah we talked about virtues is
that the other thing because here i'm
just going to say this i know that
personally
i don't really have expensive tastes
besides the stuff tim pays for you know
um so i save a lot of my money no i mean
i'm serious i don't really have
expensive tastes i save a lot of my
money and now i'm looking i'm saying
like for the past five years i've i've
lived beneath my means and basically
saved everything and that hasn't done as
much good for me as i thought it could
have i should have been spending that
stuff on assets that would increase in
value over time well you don't spend on
assets yeah you're right you invest
but the thing is even if i was just
buying stupid short-term pleasures in
some ways if inflation gets bad enough
that almost would have been better right
because you know you won't be able to
afford it with that what if you have
money what if you bought a house
at you know 3.5 or something yeah or or
5
and inflation's at 14. no yeah exactly
exactly so
here's the thing i don't understand
right like i understand how they
manipulate the cpi i understand how they
back out goods and services that are
going up because they want to get to
core cpi i understand how they don't
account for productivity gains i
understand how they gain that system but
the one system that doesn't get gamed is
the deepest most liquid market in the
world which is the bond market right and
the bond market right now says that you
can borrow money at 30 years
i think it's what like five percent or
less and so that person who is willing
to borrow or loan you that money
all this millions and billions of
dollars is willing to loan you that
money for 30 years
i don't know what the fixed rate is
right now but i think it's like five
percent or less at five percent so the
most sophisticated people in the world
with the most amount of money with the
most at risk
with the most on the line really
hedge fund managers pension fund
managers all these people they're
willing to invest that money for 30
years at less than five percent which
means that they don't think that
inflation is real
maybe or maybe it's a machine
maybe there's there's
there's a sort of mechanization how
these systems go and most people just go
along with it
you've seen the movie the big short well
yeah i have but just one more thought on
that like the financial markets are
meant to be efficient which is not
always true they're meant to have
processed all available information
which is not always true as well and
these are the most sophisticated players
most making the most sophisticated
decisions yeah and and the way that the
30-year interest rate is composed right
it has a risk premium and it has
inflation expectations in there
so uh you've seen the big short i sure
have i lived in the big short amazing
movie i was in real estate then i was in
fixed income people people knew that
people knew this was was bunk it was
broken it wouldn't make sense but they
didn't care the machine was was chugging
along well i think they thought
yeah and i i think people assume i can
still pull money out of a broken system
in the short term so i'll throw
something into it and i'll just get out
before it crashes they think they're
gonna be able to do that right but when
you're loaning money away for 30 years
you're locking yourself for 30
this is a guy these are people that have
billions and billions and billions of
dollars and they're like i'm gonna give
it to you for 30 years and you only have
to pay me five percent five percent
total on the on the capital on the yes
wow so there's no built-in inflation
expectation in long-term interest rates
well hold on which is peculiar if you
hold a hundred dollars
and inflation happens and you lose
buying power
you lose if you lend out a hundred bucks
and then 30 years later right well they
only pay you five percent but if
inflation's ten percent you're losing
either way but it's still better but
it's still better than just holding on
to the money right but there are these
people are very smart there are there
are inflation assets that respond well
to inflation like really and they
probably do have investments
i think it's a way to hedge your bets
it's like a little bit of a safer way
even even though you don't get as much
of a return i think what we're saying
here is that the bond market is
inefficient that's the only conclusion
we can be coming to i don't think you
know i think people need to understand
what money means to billionaires into
these these
even high millionaires means never
having to say you're sorry they don't
think about a hundred thousand dollars
they don't think about a couple hundred
thousand dollars no you you think they
do they don't it's acceleration it's a
form of acceleration i've i've i've been
to uh um lasagne is that the name of the
city right in switzerland i don't know
i have been in the penthouse suite of a
billionaire and it was just like they
have this 50 million dollar swiss swiss
property that they just don't care about
sure but then it was like an asset it's
gaining in value right they're fine with
that yeah so so when they're looking at
bonds they're probably like gotta invest
in something
it's better than holding cash it's true
it's entirely possible but it is the
most liquid the most the deepest and
meant to be the most efficient market on
the planet
so it's meant to reflect the sum total
wisdom of all the financial players in
the world it turns out they're not that
wise look how 2008 turned out yeah
they're not that wide that's probably it
i'm not disputing again i'm gonna get in
trouble with this i was asking you
questions about we're not disagreeing
with you questions about millie last
week you know yeah or last time and
people were like you should have heard
the way jack was shilling for millie
he's a traitor i was like dude i was
just asking some
questions chain of command and by the
way the very next day i had on cash
patel the chief of staff at the
department of defense and asked them
those questions in particular to get the
whole thing out there but uh no it's
just fascinating to me to see that maybe
the financial system is broken so like
if they could ask if you could take a
loan a bond loan of a million dollars
and then invest that at five percent
invest that into something and then
double your money well no that's the guy
that's the smart guy you're on the other
side you're saying i want to borrow five
percent heck yeah i'll borrow they're
just loaning out at five percent because
they have access to infinite no they
don't these are these are private
individuals these are institutions these
are pension funds that are investing
their money in say you know the united
states government right all these people
are loaning the united states government
money at less than five percent for 30
years
knowing that they're going to take a
bath i don't know i don't know
maybe it's an illusion i don't know all
of it is just kind of scary all i know
is i'm i'm i'm getting more real estate
i have real estate
yeah wait no i didn't just say that
smart because that might be contributed
financial advice and i would never give
it
look we're we're expanding we're buying
land and maybe it's a bubble i really
don't care
um the last thing i want to do watching
the so so the m1 money supply spiked
because they said savings are
unrestricted now savings accounts used
to have limits you can only transfer a
certain certain amount of time that's
right we talked rid of that and so i was
i was at a bank recently and they were
like do you want to open a savings or
checking i was like does it matter and
they're like well i mean
it doesn't matter anymore oh you know
what i just noticed that i transferred
money out of my savings account and
usually it says you can only transfer
five times a month or whatever and it
didn't say that dude you're right they
removed they removed the the gates that
were restricting the flow and now it's
just yeah unleashed and rich people are
snatching up assets like crazy and poor
people are going to be left holding an
empty box this is what we were saying
was going to happen years ago right i
mean i i did a cartoon about this
rich people got all the money from the
ballot they got these incredibly low
interest loans or no interest loans and
then what they were able to do is buy up
all the assets from small businesses
that shut down because they had to go
through the sba which was processing
over the course of two weeks what
they're used to processing over an
entire year or like 10 times when used
to processing over an entire year so a
bunch of small businesses shut down the
millionaires and billionaires are able
to buy all that stuff up yep and then we
end up with a massive consolidation of
corporate power people go we need to tax
the one percent and so it goes and and
they made this problem and look at the
lockdowns the destruction of the small
business
and now they're saying we're gonna find
you you know these aren't these are
still technically small businesses with
a hundred employees but now they're
coming after you i mean it is legit
but there's so many weird forces at work
too like right now if you've got a
renter in your property and they're not
paying rent you can't kick them out so
imagine all the prop you can't yeah that
ended the the cdc the supreme court
issued a new oh they're ruling and said
but either way the second time biden
came out yeah you could have still
evicted and and
so so i'm hearing these stories where
people are like biden said you have to
get a vaccine it's like him saying
something means nothing you'll go to a
court and the court's gonna courts will
side with the supreme court's decision
so the supreme court says biden you
can't do it it's illegal he can say it
you go to courtney your honor i'll cite
the supreme court and they'll be like
okay agreed right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right finds words are meaningful
so you're saying right now officially
the foreclosure thing is done it's gone
yes it really just depends on your
jurisdiction there's probably local
judges who are gonna be like i'm gonna
say no you can't evict it but the
supreme court now said it said it twice
right interesting thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you